all right everyone let's go ahead and
start to shut up now
uh welcome to ap bio seasons one and two
recap i'll try to make this brief for
you dum-dums let me catch you up to
speed i am a published harvard
philosophy professor i have no interest
whatsoever in teaching biology to you
people okay so if you keep your mouth
shut you get an a if you say anything to
anybody you get an f
as for the kids there were a few
standouts you know and there were a few
stragglers
who cared more about the rules than uh
cared about justice
as you all know this week we are
devoting our attention to the
psychological dismantling of my academic
rival
miles leonard you're seriously never
going to teach us biology at all
yeah yeah yeah that's right no i was
going to use the kids to uh
ruin the life of my rival miles i got a
lock of miles's hair boss
was that unethical maybe
did i care uh no of course not who's
gonna stop me this guy
i may be a cutie patootie but i'm still
the boss around here
or how about his painfully optimistic
secretary helen
these are examples of inappropriate
touching in the workplace
honk honk were these three bundles of
joy
so it seems like you're enjoying
yourself here god no teaching high
school in toledo
it's terrible like any rational person i
needed to get out of that place you know
unfortunately there were a
few complications i hate to tell you
this but you're sitting on a chair that
i technically bought
it's weird to say it's yours just
because you bought it
we are locked in a battle of wits with a
worthy opponent
that girl you have a crush on shut up
marcus
no sorry that's just a reflex now um
anyway i heard you say there's nothing
you'd miss if you left toledo
i would miss you this is not so bad dang
it
they said i don't have a high school
diploma well yeah because i didn't
graduate from
high school you dummies well it looks
like helen henry demarcus
is going back to high school
i teach sorry i'm turnt
good luck you remember now peanut brain
welcome to ap bios season three
you